[Music]
do you want to over the world where
everybody feels cozy and validates all
the time what do you want to live in the
world that works
we fight new Wars the old options
military diplomacy
they don't always succeed sometimes we
need a third option that's overwatch
according to the government who do not
exist we are very real and we get [ __ ]
they gonna help on this one fun nine
pounds of radioactive isotope is missing
it's enough to make six major cities
uninhabitable he knows exactly where it
is
Oh an out of the country
these ones it's for espionage we're
talking about a corrupt no level cop
you're sitting here indicates it's not
so low level you [ __ ] be careful do
you have men wandering our embassy
put me on a plane to the US and I'll
give you everything
from the 42 go there's no logic
operation
the goal is deliver that package to here
smile 22 what about the ghoul
a bike study
like cuz I can't cheat
the questing hand of God got it
Wow our angel can only stay on the down
10 minutes they miss that window they
are dead Conan Eames you tell us all the
game today
last four freeze frame on my pistol I
think I might be worse looks like a hero
cows not even a little are you I'm
totally calm that's because you're
mentally unstable thank you
[Music]